WOULD HAVE A MACHINE OR  TWO
TODAY IF THEY NEEDED IT.
AINSLEY: MR. PRESIDENT YOU HAD A
GREAT LINE WEEKS AGO THAT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CURE
IS NOT WORSE THAN THE PANDEMIC
ITSELF, AND IF YOU HEARD STORIES
ABOUT SHELLEY LUTHER DOWN IN
TEXAS WHO WAS LOCKED UP, THROWN
IN PRISON OR   IN JAIL AND FINED
A LOT OF MONEY, PEOPLE CAME OUT
OF THE WOODWORKS TO SUPPORT HER.
LOTS OF MONEY RAISED ON HER WHAT
IS IT CALLED, A GOFUNDME PAGE,
AND THEN SHAWN HANNITY LAST
NIGHT INTERVIEWED HER AND SAID
HE’S GOING TO GIVE A DONATION TO
HER AND SHE WAS FULL OF EMOTION
THERE AND THEN YOU’VE GOT THIS
SHERIFF OUT IN CALIFORNIA
WHOSE SAYING I’M NOT GOING TO
ARREST PEOPLE OR  FINE PEOPLE IF
THEY DON’T SAY OPEN UP THEIR
BUSINESSES BECAUSE I DON’T WANT
TO CRIMINALIZE PEOPLE JUST
TRYING TO WORK.
HERE IS SHELLEY LUTHER IF YOU
MISSED IT ON HANNITY LAST NIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: OKAY.
>> I JUST WOKE UP ONE DAY AND I
SAID I HAVE TO OPEN, MY STYLISTS
ARE CALLING ME THEY’RE NOT
MAKING THEIR MORTGAGE.
I WAS RIGHT NOW I STILL AM NOT
CAUGHT UP.
I’M TWO MONTHS BEHIND ON MY
MORTGAGE, AND MY STYLISTS WERE
TELLING ME THAT THEY WANTED TO,
WHAT DO YOU THINK IF I GO
UNDERGROUND AND GO TO PEOPLE’S
HOUSES AND I JUST SAID THAT’S
NOT A GOOD IDEA BECAUSE WE CAN’T
CONTROL THE ENVIRONMENT THERE.
WE DON’T KNOW IF ITS BEEN DIS
INFECTED OR  ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, AND I JUST DECIDED I WOULD
OPEN TO CREATE A SAFE PLACE FOR
THE STYLISTS AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT I WASN’T THE REASON
THEY WEREN’T MAKING MONEY.
AINSLEY: MR. PRESIDENT WHAT WAS
YOUR REACTION WHEN THAT JUDGE
THREW HER IN JAIL FOR SEVEN DAYS
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I THOUGHT IT
WAS TERRIBLE.
I THOUGHT HE WAS A TERRIBLE
JUDGE.
THE GOVERNOR AGREED WITH ME
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THEY HAVE
A GREAT ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
TEXAS, BUT THE GOVERNOR WAS WITH
ME YESTERDAY, GREG ABBOTT HE’S A
FANTASTIC GOVERNOR.
HE COULDN’T BELIEVE IT, AND
SHE’S AN INCREDIBLE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR A LARGE GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT WANT TO DO THE
SAME THING.
THEY WANT TO GET BACK TO WORK.
THESE PEOPLE WANT TO GET BACK TO
WORK.
WE KNOW EVERYBODY HAS DONE WHAT
THEY HAVE DONALD YOU COULD ONLY
DO THAT SO LONG AND THAT CAUSES
DEATH ALSO, IF YOU LOOK AT ALL
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
WITH DRUGS AND SUICIDE AND THEY
LOSE THEIR JOBS AND ANXIETY AND
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
CAUSED BY THAT, THAT’S A BIG
PROBLEM TOO.
PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE THAT AND I
WILL TELL YOU, YOU LOOK AT SOME
CASES, SOME PEOPLE THINK THEY’RE
DOING IT FOR POLITICS HERE WE GO
AGAIN, BUT THEY THINK THEY ARE
DOING IT BECAUSE IT’LL HURT ME
THE LONGER IT TAKES TO HURT ME
IN THE ELECTION, THE LONGER IT
TAKES TO OPEN UP AND I CAN SEE
SOME OF THAT BECAUSE SOME OF
THESE, SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
BEING UNREALISTIC.
THEY’RE BEING RIDICULOUS.
I’VE LOOKED AT A COUPLE OF
STATES THAT ARE BEING ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS BUT ULTIMATELY, THE
PEOPLE ARE FORCING IT.
I SEE WHAT’S GOING ON AND GAVIN
NEWSOM HAS BEEN VERY GENEROUS TO
ME IN HIS STATEMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE IT BUT I THINK THEY
CAN MOVE A LITTLE QUICKER IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE HONEST AND I
THINK THE PEOPLE ARE FORCING IT.
THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FORCE IT
NOW NOT IN ALL CASES.
IN SOME CASES YOU HAVE TO KEEP
IT GOING LONGER BUT WE’VE
LEARNED THINGS IN THE LAST TWO
MONTHS WE’VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
IT AND WE MAY HAVE FIRES AND
WE’RE GOING TO PUT THE FIRES OUT
WE MAY I HAVE SAY EMBERS, BUT WE
ALSO MAY HAVE SOME FIRES AND
SOME REASONABLY BIG ONES, BUT
WE’LL PUT THEM OUT.
WE’VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THIS
DISEASE AND BUT YOU CAN’T
JUST, WE CAN’T CLOSE OUR COUNTRY
FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU KNOW, I HAD ONE DOCTOR WHO
SAYS WELL WE COULD KEEP IT TWO
OR  THREE YEARS THAT BE
WONDERFUL.
YOU WOULDN’T HAVE A COUNTRY, IT
WOULD BREAK AND WE’RE GOING TO
HAVE A FANTASTIC NEXT YEAR.
WE WILL HAVE A RECORD OR  ALMOST
-RECORD NEXT YEAR, WE’RE
GOING TO HAVE A TRANSITION IN
THE THIRD QUARTER AND IT’S
HAPPENING ALREADY.
YOU CAN SEE IT AND THE SPIRIT
NOW, THERE’S A LOT OF SPIRIT
BECAUSE WE HAVE OVER 30 STATES
THAT ARE BACK, ARE VERY STRONGLY
COMING BACK AND THAT’S GOING TO
BE A LOT HIGHER SOON.
THERE’S A TRANSITION THAT’S
TAKING PLACE SO THE THIRD
QUARTER IS GOING TO BE A
TRANSITION.
FOURTH QUARTER I THINK IS GOING
TO BE VERY GOOD, AND I THINK
NEXT YEAR WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
ONE OF THE BEST YEARS WE’VE EVER
HAD IF YOU DON’T HAVE SOMEBODY
GETTING IN AND GUMMING UP THE
WORKS AND DOUBLING AND
TRIPLING YOUR TAXES LIKE SLEEPY